- Who's there?
- Ach.
- Ach (sneezing).
- God bless you.
- Thank you, Father.
- You're welcome.
- Who's there?
- Nikesh.
- Nikesh who?
- No, I wear Re-bach shoe,
two of them actually.
Re-bach!
- Those are fresh.
- Re-bach!
- Who's there?
- I gotta go, Pa.
- I gotta go Pa who?
- Oh, you gotta go poo?
Here's the key,
bathroom's out back.
Wipe up.
- Thanks.
- Who's there?
Purse who?
- Okay, you wanna go
out some time, then?
Smell it, come on,
one date, babe.
I like you, eh?
I'm totally going
for it over here!
- Who's there?
- Contin.
- Contin who?
- Okay, I will continue.
My name is Brent.
I knock on doors,
I knock on wood.
I got my first pair of
knuckles when I was born.
- Who's there?
- Kung.
- Kung who?
(cheering)
- [Announcer] Block
it, take that.
Who's there, SEGA.